[Musique]
vicent emails tweets shader cher
monsieur koga bonjour team cher shoji
des century girl
j'espère que vous vous portez bien il y
a trop longtemps qu'on s'est vus nous
allons bien qu en est il de vous et de
votre famille à the sun setting for a
new beginning tokyo
nous avons tous très hâte de nous
retrouver à montréal pour une réunion
après la pandémie
je suis très enthousiaste à l'idée de
vous revoir à montréal et de continuer
nos discussions
njawe project64 project jeu serait
inapproprié pour moi d'endosser
publiquement le projet d'une compagnie
en particulier le plus grand soin est
nécessaire pour que cette information ne
soit pas divulguée 10 pipeau un geste et
nibali leader in japan non le 20e
premier ministre du canada
[Musique]
bonne nouvelle les libéraux sont de
retour et image exchange inc
un dépôt géologique en profondeur des
combustibles nucléaires usés
ainsi creed project forsythe histoire
nous courions ouest qui est in canada a
project is being taken by canadiennes
américaines et japonaises businessmen
[Musique]
10 when we are whist chef
au programme découverte
ça c'est le combustible qui alimente les
centrales nucléaires cette grappe n'est
pas radioactives
mais lorsqu'elle sera placé dans une
centrale elle deviendra un déchet qui
demeurera radioactifs pendant des
centaines de milliers d'années
au canada on veut construire un tombeau
nucléaire pour enterrer 5 millions de
ces grappes de casting
les japonais sont très intéressés par un
dépôt géologique en profondeur dans le
bouclier précambrien au canada
philippe le japon avant fukushima avait
54 électeurs en fonction ce qui veut
dire que ont une consommation de
combustible nucléaire qui est importante
et qui se traduit par la production de
déchets alors c'est un très très gros
problème
surtout qu'en plus il ya 21 réacteurs
qui va être démantelée dans les années
qui viennent ici et s'il est apte story
nous reste à faire
mais le problème c'est que comme d'une
selle japon c'est une paire sismique
donc une terre qui bouge beaucoup et
donc il ya beaucoup de problèmes pour
déterminer un site idéal donc la
question du stockage des déchets se pose
pour les japonais in dreams ouïe fine 10
paragraphe
j'ai confiance que des canadiens tourné
vers l'avenir seront utilisés les
ressources nécessaires pour la
réalisation d'un dépôt de portée
mondiale pour la livraison et le
stockage sécuritaire des combustibles
nucléaires usés
win again in canada for ever ah si ça se
faisait ça serait sensationnel
parce que ça ne s'est jamais fait et il
ya de bonnes raisons pourquoi ça c'est
pas fait exprès
d'une part cédé matière extrêmement
radioactive donc extrêmement dangereux
pour donner une idée à un mètre de
distance si un combustible irradié n'est
pas protégé la dose létale crâne humain
c'est en moins d'une minute
oui à steam trading gibbs la première
réaction a été une stupéfaction à quel
point des gens extrêmement haut placés
se rassemblent dans une espèce de
conspiration
incroyable une conspiration clairement
destiné à garder au secret un plan est
de le faire avancer suffisamment loin
pour confronter les décideurs avec des
fait accompli for michael snyder
distribuer les gouvernements c'est par
définition des questions qui doivent
être gérés dans l'intérêt public et en
aucun cas dans l'intérêt de quelques
sociétés privées que ce soit donc c'est
déjà la démarche en soi est extrêmement
problématique par l'origine de cette
démarche de m
c'est quelqu'un qui a tué qui a une
position très élevé actuellement il est
vice présidente de d'hitachi il est
quelqu'un qui a un passé de hauts
responsables du ministère de l'énergie
du département le manager aux états unis
parmi les personnes impliquées dont j'ai
connaissance c'est l'anglais in addition
to working fuji hitachi jim freeman the
world
la compagnie a même pas un dossier
200 mm
je pense que c'est vraiment important
takuya terroristes
c'est vraiment quelqu'un de très très
très important dans le monde dans ce
qu'on appelle le village nucléaire ici
email
isa fumiko gars of the japanese la chine
ferme ce cas aussi il est très important
parce que par sa position et puis parce
que il est aussi un homme de réseau un
homme relativement secret qui qui
connaît beaucoup de monde là on a avec
ces deux personnalités on a vraiment de
deux acteurs importants des réseaux
politico industrielle du japon
il n'y a absolument aucune question que
les japonais impliqués dans ce plan
secret sont des gens au profil we know i
make up on me now we know where we find
le green it sec du labrador serait
parfait pour cette utilisation
bingo l'abbé robert barbault de nigel
[Musique]
sony y est des 6 dreads bol exprimé de
province entre leicester
besides the speed of staff greg
marketing six compagnies including
[Musique]
japanese partner chez jc comme vous le
savez peut-être le premier ministre
baird a annoncé qu'il va démissionner et
qu'un nouveau chef sera nommé le 3 août
cela dit nous prévoyons rester en
contact avec le premier ministre bat o
de sorte que la transition devrait se
faire en douceur à ce mouvement chrétien
[Musique]
oui bonjour aux copilotes man in the
browser
le projet entend thèse c'est quoi ok
jack tu es ce que vous avez parlé à des
japonais qui sont engagés dans ce projet
acteur au talent et au bar boutique
étude met il ya au cours de mes plus de
40 ans au sein du gouvernement et dans
la vie publique
j'ai cultivé invite intérêt pour tous
les aspects de l'énergie nucléaire
je sais bien qu'il serait inapproprié
pour moi ce stade-ci d'endosser le
projet d'une entreprise en particulier
j'ai toujours été publiquement
favorables à l'énergie nucléaire
et au concept d'un dépôt géologique en
profondeur dans le nord est du canada
nation energy consulting
ce que je trouve incroyablement
scandaleux c'est que quelqu'un avec ce
profil là utilise son nom pour ouvrir
des portes pour un projet qui est
totalement clandestin un projet en
dehors de tout tout contrôle public
oui aux sports denis saint martin dans
ma recherche et avec d'autres ont un
peso la politique silencieuse donc ça ça
se fait exactement comme décrit dans les
courriels vie il y aura le temps
d'aligner leurs pions pendant 3 4 10 ans
donc il va aller sans chercher des
autochtones favorable à leur projet ils
vont aller chercher des certifications
de greenpeace ou d'autres organismes
mondiale qui vont dire que c'est beau
puis que oui c'est dans l'intérêt
national canadien et ce dans l'intérêt
mondial de le faire oui mais quoi
find more we come back jean chrétien
tutelle mme we have the decision
pas eu de tremblement terre qu'on sache
au labrador
c'est un acte extrêmement dur alors
l'idée c'est de faire des forages et
d'aller déposer les déchets nucléaires à
5000 pièces dyson et nous la canada ont
été les vendeurs d'uranium
c'est à dire qu'on a profité de ce
problème parce qu'on a vendu le gagnant
alors on à rennes responsabilité d'aider
à régler le problème est qu elle soit le
canada madd de l'uranium à travers le
monde comme le dévoile quelque pays que
ce soit alors s'il y en a qui veulent la
paix ils veulent payer pour un concours
photo jean-christophe canada ce qui me
sicogaz l'économie moins que le bureau
mamadou sy jean vergnes est j'ai dit oui
préparez l'allèle l'élu lui les signes
vous signez actifs d'anciens premiers
ministres québécois sera écouté j'ai je
savais pas que ça écrit comme ça je me
rappelle programme à part que je signe
et j'ai lu adepte et japon a marqué son
jeu c'est la première fois que c'est
l'avocat qu'il a rien à voir avec votre
statut assez prononcé mais connaissant
ce que je veux c'est un peu un abus de
27 vous trouvez c'est un abus oui que
vous le valez il a envoyé le jugement
[Musique]
elle écrit good news
la broadback c'est vrai père news gens
ça c'est vous has not been appointed by
justin trudeau asie et pourquoi écrire
ça oui ben ali lui demander non c'est le
commerce dans vos accès au pouvoir
dicter qui fait c'est lui qui le fait
si richard et banham mais s'il vous dit
que ceux qui mènent le maillot
[Musique]
les vracs nice jean chrétien quiz
working girl cours d'eau je suis venu
pour jouer quelqu'un l'a coaché pas
qu'ils n'ont ils viennent mixs way to
this entry
le but de la question c'est que les
journalistes vous demande qui vous venez
rencontrez vous vous dites je le sais
pas non on apprend que vous travaillez
pour des projets comme ça comme un
projet jouir de stockage de déchets
nucléaires en avez vous parlé à
quelqu'un gouvernement de ce projet là
non je peux parler au premier ministre
oblige je veux pas l'intention de lui en
parler du tout non plus je ne fais pas
de la bible personnes d'autres personnes
qui peuvent faire rêver nos deux ya peu
y a pas de dossier viavil gouvernement
ada il ne pas y alliez il n'y a même pas
de projet je n'ai même pas ficelé vous
faites pas de lobbying non vous parlait
jamais des projets des clients en eau à
des personnes qui sont en autorité nous
vous l'avez jamais fait non
donc je fais pas de lobbying pourquoi
parce que je veux pas faire de la baie
ça m'intéresse pas d'aller parler aux
fonctionnaires un essai vu des
fonctionnels à ma vie car en talent chez
moi j'ai mon copain n'est ce pas c'est
pas que les japonais se disent tu
exactement à ceux qui s'insurgent ce
qu'ils veulent les japonais je vous dis
qu'est ce que je fais et logic of
japanese saint jean chrétien que d'open
world riders à croiser canada
j'organiserai et participerez à des
discussions au canada dans ces provinces
et dans des pays potentiellement
partenaires pour faire avancer le projet
d'un dépôt en profondeur dans le
nord-est canadien qu'est-ce que vous
êtes au japonais vous allez faire jeudi
que
le projet je travaille pour le projet et
je dis que je m'intéresse à ce projet
l'un veut que ça marche et dansant la
bayard des discussions et si je peux
participer je participerai
[Musique]
il a soumis qu'aux galeries cependant de
jean chrétien
je suis tout à fait disposé à travailler
avec vous j'ai été réellement
impressionné par votre noble idée et par
votre proposition visionnaire hands with
words
en terminant il me fait plaisir
d'accepter votre invitation à une
réunion du groupe de travail à montréal
ou à ottawa en novembre à fourmies koga
undercovers de signer le plus grand soin
est nécessaire pour que cette
information ne soit pas divulguée mais
les déchets qui sont enterrés là ils
disparaissent pas fixé en métaux ils
vont être l'ogre milanais
dix mille a dit mina et ben ya peut-être
un problème dans dix mille ans on
laissera aux policiers de cette époque
là à leur ai dit vous travaillez pas ce
que chose de bien cela et c'était plutôt
des l'association que des vérités et ses
potes à la profession mais moi je pense
que parler d'un projet secret de
stockage de déchets nucléaires de ce
chrétien c'est très d'intérêt public
je pense que c'est doubt intérêts
publics oui j'ai répondu à vos questions
ouais may a priori et de cynisme des cas
vous voyez votre avocat détenus au
secret professionnel connaissent pas
american tower of a more words in 6/4
6/2 2/6 le public